let's go to our next caller from the 209
area code 209 go ahead 209 are you there
I hear dishes Oh brushing your teeth
other okay okay my question is why do
conservatives always bring up Venezuela
as like the talking point right but it
doesn't really mean anything what do you
think it's so prevalent in their
argument against socialism or democratic
socialism yeah democracy I don't know
because it's convenient most people
don't really know anything about it I
mean you've got this see I actually
think the left enables the right to use
Venezuela in that way and what I mean is
that there's a contingent of the left
and I've talked about them before and
there's sort of this triad of opinions
and it's defense for the authoritarian
regimes of Hugo Chavez and look Nikolas
Maduro sort of defense of Bashar al-asad
skepticism of the Russia story beyond
anything that you could imagine being
reasonable and disdain and hatred for
Israel right it's this sort of quad this
is sort of these four positions there's
this contingent on the left and I think
that they actually enable the right to
talk about Venezuela in a way that's
more effective because there is this
contingent of the left that holds up
Venezuela is some kind of true leftist
paradise and of course it's not it's
very very far from that so I think that
that the right does it because they get
value out of it and part of the value is
created from there being a contingent on
the left I think I saw I hope I'm not
miss speaking I think on the 50th
anniversary of the assassination of
Martin Luther King which was recently
arty ran a piece in some way drawing a
parallel between Martin Luther King and
either Nicolas Maduro or Hugo Chavez or
it might have been one of those other
South American TV networks it was this
crazy and it's just that that is what
enables the right to then say look at
the disaster of Venezuela because if the
left didn't defend that authoritarian in
perversion of so-called socialism the
right wouldn't get value out of saying
look
these people on the Left who like what's
going on in Venezuela when it's a
disaster right if the left was like no
that's a perversion of social democracy
or whatever I think the left would be
much better off well another thing I
want to ask was so you're from Argentina
right that's Correll was wondering if
you would you would like going to do a
new story on so the Argentinian
Argentinian
economic situation right now yeah I mean
every once in a while I talk about
Argentinian politics it it doesn't seem
that interesting to most of our audience
but the economy is in major major
trouble and it has been for a long time
that's why my family ended up in the
United States but I'll look into talking
about Argentina more in the future
but that's certainly something I would
consider